herzlich willkommen zu diesem neuen
video leute ich habe in der letzten zeit
ziemlich viel gekocht ich habe für
verschiedene gäste gekommen ich habe die
besten dinge der welt gekocht und ich
dachte mir ich muss mich heute mal eine
auszeit gönnen und zum glück habe ich
sehr viel info elisa kollegen die
mittlerweile schon eigene produkte auf
den markt gebracht
aus dem food bereich also
fertigmahlzeiten in der regel
fertigmahlzeiten und es sind so viele
dass ich mir einen tag lang nur davon
ernähren kann was ich heute mache werde
ich freue mich sehr auf den tag
überhaupt nicht kochen kann essen
bestellen einfach mal bisschen
fertigmahlzeiten will
es ist jetzt gerade mittwochmorgen und
ich fühle mich nach einem leichten start
in den tag und guten kaffee da kommt
auch schon unsere beiden kandidaten fürs
frühstück ins spiel kamen die ios-app
urlauber scheinen da drin zu sein sieht
sehr gut aus und oft zusätzlich eine
banane kokosmilch und einen mixer und
dann halt und möchte toppings für
obendrauf marktcafé habe ich hier die
rallye geschenkt hat sich für ihn
gekocht habe ist schon fast wäre ich
habe schon viel davon getrunken aber ihr
krieges quasi mein feedback dazu also
kümmern wir uns als erstes mal um das
ipad habe ihm gesagt die sachen die ich
dazu brauch ich brauche 50 milliliter
kokosmilch das sind 160 und das kleinste
lose wie es irgendwie gar auf der welt
auf der welt einfach nicht nur bei ihren
supermarkt diese beiden hier die kamera
auch frieren wenn wir uns noch ein
bisschen kühler haben will aber das hier
kommt aus der tiefkühltruhe ist maximal
auf eingefrorene blogs das sind zwei
drin aber das hier ist jetzt eigentlich
weiß man dass gekostet hat ich glaube
irgendwie 44 euro oder so und knackig
was man auch sagen muss hier stets
schütze den regen weil mit deinem die
uracher schäferlauf von einkaufspreis
abführen
rain post von deutschen oder so es ist
erst mal nicht ganz einfach auf zu
bekommen die aus wie mit komischem
schokoriegel hat gar keine süße ich
dachte irgendwas versüßt
dazu kommen so banane weil man halbieren
und jetzt die kokosmilch
50 davon nur das kommen also auch dazu
gute jeden steht camps powerball drauf
die gute fügte noch einen esslöffel
agaven dixa zu wahrscheinlich bei
kleinen künstler zu verdrehen war nicht
immer so ein bisschen ab und sirup also
dann leute das soll ja mein verständnis
jetzt schon alles sein was wir machen
müssen was mit uns los pürieren
heute bin ich mal sehr gespannt browser
frühstück habe ist auf jeden fall sehr
fans wie muss man schon sagen bin mir
nur nicht sicher ob das eine richtige
mahlzeit ersetzen soll weil es ist
wirklich nicht super finde dann werde
ich das ganze noch toppen mit ein paar
kokosraspeln und ein paar mandeln so der
karten von marx nennt sich gentleman
stories video sehen könnt und hat 70
prozent arabica 30% robuster
die besonderheit von marx kp ist das hat
er mir erzählt dass er einen höheren
koffein anteil hat als gewöhnliche
kaffee ist also den höchsten koffein
anteil auf dem markt bei magna so extrem
typ das waren schon mal richtig
geschmack lustig ausübung und
vollmundiger körper cremige schokolade
trist datum elfter erster 221 von hand
drauf geschrieben sehr wild ist aber
auch ein absoluter premium kaffee also
vom preis her muss ich wirklich sagen
aber dann wollen wir mal ich mal 18
gramm rein und wir schauen dass wir 36
rausbekommen
sieht super aus schöne krämer dann
schauen wir noch ein bisschen milch
trinke nämlich als cappuccino
hier ist super geworden aber ich freue
mich schon sehr muss ich sagen
darauf freue ich mich auch sehr ich
meine dem café ihr habt so gesehen habe
ich schon viel getrunken dir was man
immer nur das püree pur
ultratronik eine geschmacklich dominiert
die ballade das absolut aber ist nur
leichte ohne seligkeit schluss kommt von
dem was sehr sehr lecker aber muss ich
sagen und man fühlt sich auch bei dessen
schon gut wird ist das ein bildung weil
das halt so super gut ist aber eins und
per kopf bei eur/pln oktober schon eine
kölner auf jeden fall also der kaffee
supergut also ich muss sagen die beiden
nachts schon mal alles richtig gemacht
habe drei vier kilo kaffee übels lecker
so hat doch der tag schon mal gut
gestartet ich bin gespannt was ist zum
mittag geben wird machen wir weiter mit
mittagessen und zwar mit der ganz neu
erschienenen ohne justin spices
reispfanne erstmal 77 cent ich war sehr
überrascht ich doch irgendwie so ein
bisschen teurer
wir lesen aber mal drauf also es ist
jetzt kein klassisches fertig gericht
aber es immer noch einen förster produkt
ich habe ihn noch frische sachen bolt
ist und frühlingszwiebeln damit paprika
möhren und ein wenig hof wo wir halten
das ganze natürlich im sinne von ungarn
beim mittagessen die paprika waschen
entkernen und den 3 mm dicke streifen
schneiden
letztlich ist es wirklich ein sehr
entspannter tag für mich heute weil
jetzt mal zum beispiel so viel sagen ich
hätte einfach schon mal habe ich für
niemanden geringeres als jumbo facchin
schreiner gekocht galileo zum bruch das
kommt diesen sonntag um 14 uhr die ich
schwör's ihnen das nicht guckt seid ihr
einfach unendlich dumm also new york ist
richtig cool da habe ich bin ich habe
ich natürlich auch sehr ins zeug gelegt
aber heute bin ich schon ganz
entspannter tag einfach ein paar fertige
infos
so macht er das 3 mm dünne scheiben und
braucht eigentlich auch erbsen aber ich
schwöre ich habe einfach keine erbsen
bekommt darf mir auch zuhören jetzt so
in zwei supermärkten
dann habe ich ein paar warme geholt ich
glaube das passt aber auch super gut
rein so paprikas geschnitten ist eine
ganze menge hinter der kamera hallo und
kann dort kostenlos mit essen kostenlos
bei dem standen langzeit projekt am
laufen wo er einfach nur bis sparen will
also realistisch leben da kommt es
natürlich gelegen wenn der büro kollege
eine schöne umreißt alle im chor ist da
wo wir zwei lauf zwiebeln das im
frühling 2007 als kind davon ab und die
soll man dann einfach so in einen
millimeter dicke scheiben schneiden
ich hoffe ich kriege so hin wie er sich
wünscht dies vorstellt so wir stellen
eine falle auch so dann sollen wir jetzt
zwei carrolls eigentlich sollte man sie
stehen wir haben keinen schicker im büro
ist aber auch kein problem ist jetzt
noch mal schnell ab und dann passt das
auf jeden fall zwei millimeter dicke
scheiben persönlich mit immer mal
interessieren eigentlich wie nah so
jemand die ungefähr so was an der
produktentwicklung dran ist ja jeder von
den leuten zu riskant sehr
unterschiedlich seien ja sonst komplett
ist früher film mit angebot und führen
dass die leute vor aktiv auch
produzenten herantreten
ich mach mal einen hype von denen
irgendwelche darauf unsere sind ein
bisschen größer so ungefähr 1 esslöffel
öl geben wir da rein und da gehen jetzt
mal paprika und karotten rein und
dünsten die ein bisschen an
musst du den reis nicht schon parallel
machen dauert doch bestimmt ein bisschen
länger mit in der farm gemacht es dürfte
aber glaube ich dass gesundes differenz
zurück sein was ich heute habe seinen
wohl bestimmt auch gute stimmung dazu
geben jetzt direkt unseren reis und den
braten wir auch noch kurz mit an wenn
der reis auch ein bisschen angebracht
ist möchten wir das ganze mit sojasoße
ab auch wieder so etwa ein esslöffel
damit auch von seiten des staates
verzichten
nur 500 milliliter
und jetzt kommt das eigentliche produkt
auch daran nämlich die würzmischung
gespannt wie sie riecht aber sehr sehr
intensiv und sehr lecker ja gespannt
mehr dazu und
und das braucht jetzt einfach mit ein
ist auch den reichlich gehört also es
muss möglich
flavor seien eigentlich das kommen wir
jetzt zu 15 minuten freude es gibt ein
sehr beliebtes infos produkt was
eigentlich schon ausverkauft war und ich
hab mal nachgefragt ob sie vielleicht
eine chance gibt dass ich für dieses
video doch was bekomme und guckt euch
das mal an glaube das ist alles voll mit
rob ships das heißt die können wir
gleich auch noch testen was für ein
timing die sachen kamen wirklich heute
an und gedanken nicht haben vor einer
minute und also ich erwarte nicht dass
sie kommen ihr seht homfeld eingebracht
das gesamte wasser wir geben jetzt 100
gramm soja bohnen also jeder machen dazu
beziehungsweise erbsen so bleibt das
ganze jetzt noch mal so für drei minuten
drin geht vielleicht noch mal ein
schluck wasser darüber ist schon sehr
sehr trocken ist und das ist anderen
aber auch unsere frühlings trieben
kombination gern spaßige fünfte
sojabohnen aufgetaucht dann ist auch
schon unsere uwe reitz fahne fertig ich
kenne sieht auch nach ungarn aus was
würdest du sagen ja vor allem die die
bohnen machen wollen
[Musik]
also leute war hier sitzen wir die
unerreichbare sieht sehr schmackhafte ja
auf jeden fall
ich bin natürlich es kommt darauf an
dies das ganze gewürzt
darauf bin ich gespannt dass man beide
gaben probieren ja wir geben euch das
volle review wenn wir auf gewesen
wir sind schon fast fertig mit dem essen
und meine benotung ist das ist erst mal
ein geiles rezept was man dazu bekommen
weil man fühlt sich auch etwa gut danach
also ist jetzt nichts was einen ausläuft
oder so bin ich sehr gut wir haben
selbst gesehen so ein bisschen bei der
schärfe nachgeholfen
ich mag das immer sehr gerne du auch bei
so asiatisch angehauchten berichtet
wollen wenn ein bisschen kick dran ist
verständlich warum das nicht in der
westböhmischen geschmeckt aber super und
würde ich sagen dass eine gute grundlage
für dieses rezept bemerken wir dass auch
bisher hinterher habe ich nicht bewertet
okay aber ich würde dem neun von zehn
geben weil es schnell wie sie gut es ist
auch es gibt auch einen push in die
richtige richtung für die zuschauer
leistung so die anderen produkte gehen
vielleicht eher in der einfache fastfood
richtung das hier ist finde ich cool
dass es in eine andere richtung gibt
könnt ihr auch gut
ich möchte erstmal ein ausgedehntes
chips review die reispfanne hat sich
langsam gesetzt und zum glück habe ich
dieses beschauliche paket von jobs
bekommen ich habe alle
geschmacksrichtungen von robs ich hab
paprika sour cream meersalz und ich
würde sagen ich probiere noch mal alle
oder weil man gönnt sich ja sonst nicht
bekomme ich als erstes lust ich würde
sagen sorry ich hab vergessen eigentlich
mal chipstüten unten auf was ich da
gemacht und damit das sind sie muss
ehrlich sein ich habe schon mal rocks
gegessen aber es ist ein bisschen mehr
aber man muss sagen sind wirklich
premium chips kuppel ja auch mal die
größe an manchen aber es gibt auch
deutlich größere noch sehr knusprig der
sehr sehr geil gesagt ich muss einfach
damit wird das video verstehen muss ich
einfach noch mehr probieren es ist
leider so wir gehen wir auch das
neutrale zwischendurch
mehr seit bau deutet es an es ist kein
spaß
wir sind wirklich knuspriger als kombi
chips was für ein geiles video einfach
heute
und die letzten im grunde also rost
hilfst du dich sehr sehr welt afrikas
hätten einen mit einer süßen würzige
note lasst euch sagen dass wir gute
repräsentation für die infos aus dem
real- trainer war besser als die
allermeisten gypsy man so im supermarkt
kaufen können zehn von zehn und war auch
zum abschluss des tages zum abendessen
da ich kein geringerer als kapital
bemüht ist jetzt vielleicht klassisch
genommen streng genommen kein in ver di
luca pizza hätte es auch gegeben gibt
aber nicht mehr ist sollte auch hier
gibt es noch und super lag das war genau
genommen die letzte und habe ich einmal
probiert glaube ich war sehr gespannt
ich meine mich zu erinnern dass ihn sehr
knusprigen boden hatte wir müssen
erstmal den backofen auf 225 grad
beheizt also dann wollen wir mal der
backofen ist vorgeheizt aus dem
gefrierfach direkt rein plätzen zehn bis
zwölf minuten backen ist schon relativ
klein muss ich sagen aber ist dafür dass
reichlich belegt muss man auch sagen
also nicht schlecht für eine pizza und
erwarten
[Musik]
dann kommen wir auch schon zum großen
finale ich bin ein bisschen traurig und
ehrlich zu sein es war eigentlich alles
super lecker heute aber auf jeden fall
props an alle deren produkte dabei war
alles super super lecker und wir
probieren jetzt die kapital pizza
klavier habt gehört meiner erinnerung
war auf jeden fall richtig der boden ist
super knusprig irgendwie und auch die
pizza ist wirklich wieder besser als
viele andere tiefkühlpizzen die man so
kaufen kann
ich weiß dass ich noch kurz zu sagen so
kann man sich auf jeden fall gut rein
können ich hoffe dass wieder viel spaß
gemacht vielleicht kann ich davon noch
ein teil 2 machen und ich weiß nicht wie
viele verschiedene info produkten noch
gibt auf dem markt viel cooler held
könnt ihr auch noch unsere gerne
kommentieren aber ansonsten war das ein
sehr cooler tag immer sehr coole
erfahrung wir sehen uns am sonntag beim
video mit jumbo also schaut auf jeden
fall vermeiden